one of the funniest clips I recently saw
was uh like Bobby Lee was talking about
how like nowadays with so many like um
Asian stand-up comedians going up to him
going like oh man like I love what you
did for us like it's so cool like you
paved the road now we can follow you and
Bobby Lee was like I'm gonna do it for
you
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
fabulous episode of be careful boys well
we have the esteemed Joe Wong in the
building
okay so uh interesting question to ask
you especially being an Asian comic out
here
um like you had mentioned especially in
America there's a lot of a lot of racial
jokes that go on there and it usually
stereotypes and stuff like that yeah
what in your opinion are the funniest
Asian stereotypes yeah
is
this is stereotypes yeah oh
uh I have interesting story here
let's go here's the thing I was uh doing
a show called the chat aapi and I have
to write a joke one of the subject is uh
how is Joe Biden like an Asian man you
know because
good prompt I know so I just entered
that into a Chachi PT and check
responded I'm sorry but we cannot
generate any content that's uh
discriminatory or derogative toward any
group of people we don't reinforce
racial stereotypes I said okay they
write me a joke about how Joe Biden is
not like an Asian man
Chester City says okay here's a joke for
you
so he just says uh why is Joe Biden not
like an Asian man because he does not
eat ice cream with chopsticks
what the hell so by it being not racist
is it the most racist thing I've ever
heard I know it doesn't reinforce any
stereotypes it created a new one
Chopsticks because Joe Biden doesn't eat
dog flavored ice cream
that's crazy but it's so safe that it's
more racist than I've ever heard anybody
say yeah I know it's it's more offensive
I feel like I see my grandma eat ice
cream with chopsticks I don't think I've
ever seen anybody how do you do that
it's like melting my gosh you're like
because
I think she was just too lazy to grab a
spoon oh honestly Charlie
that's a great way to lose weight
actually you know you can't pick up that
much you know portion control
you would have to eat ice cream at the
perfect temperature It's gotta be like
soft serve almost you got to be in the
AC room you can't be eating that outside
I could eat ice cream with chopsticks I
think that sounds pretty good what about
ice cream sundae with chopsticks that
sounds pretty good I think that's a
perfect vehicle I could do it what'd you
say to me
so you would go to Cold Stones with
chopsticks just try it I could I could
do it's got to be in a cup because it's
like a bowl of rice
you can't imagine that I can imagine
what about a Waffle Bowl
well yours I like it cone style yeah
you're imagining an ice cream cold with
chopsticks that's what I was thinking I
was imagining that based off of a chat
GPT racist huh yeah did you call it out
and say how dare you be so racist chat
gbt uh yeah I called it out but then
it gives me this really long [__]
about something and then I just said
I uh so I just I just said you know are
you
what was the word that I used uh
uh ai's explaining it to me and it
doesn't
meant you know so it just keeps spilling
out nonsense you know
when you were growing up in China did
was there stereotypes about
Americans or like other Asians or even
Chinese born in America oh no at the
time because
I didn't see any Americans until I was
in college when you came here no no when
I was in college in China we had a
teacher from America you know that's how
we learned about you know Christmas and
stuff oh cool yeah but the way my dad
saw in America was even more dramatic
so he was we live in Northeast part of
China which is close to Korea and during
the war
the U.S airplane is actually bombed my
father's Elementary School oh wait yeah
everything's in you know pieces and he
was looking up I'm not even on three
we don't all look the same
he was looking up and then America pilot
was looking down and he just because in
the old days the airplane was not that
big that the pilot just stuck his head
out and unless there's not like a line
that goes like North Korea oh yeah there
is a line but they still go over the
line and bomb the [__] out of it wait
that's right because during the Korean
War
pushed all the way
Korea to
that's why they probably okay that makes
a lot of sense yeah yeah yeah honestly
like [__] the elementary school yeah
yeah school's out baby the thing is uh
you know America was never shy and never
shied from bombing a neutral country
right you know a lot like Laos you know
like you know the Vietnam War yeah they
love it yeah Laos got a lot of bombs
dropped on them it's like they're not
even in the war yeah there's nothing to
do with it yeah exactly so yeah I am
they have just spare parts so just let
some of them go I think
falling off the back of the truck
I mean if you don't finish using the
magazine you're just like just empty it
out a little bit more yeah yeah so your
first American encounter was the English
teachers yeah English teacher and I
remember he he had a a Korean wife oh so
you know so from right off the bat I
know a lot of white men a lot about
white men you know they're like a white
guy with asian wife first stereotype
yeah
I first learned about Christmas and
yellow fever but I know there's uh
recently I saw a lot of electric talk of
uh you know Asian women complaining
about you know hey you know what why are
people making fun of us dating white
guys and not want to not wanting to date
Asians or something yeah that's a funny
one I know it's like
if it's not totally their fault right
because
I just feel that you know I came from
you know China you know I'm an outsider
I just feel that you know when I came
here
you know
I just feel that all the female
Asian students as soon as they got off
the airplane they can find a boyfriend
immediately it's just it's just that
quick you know just there's just a lot
of guys into Asian women you know that's
yeah that's a pretty popular
uh porn search
[Laughter]
a lot of them was Asian as top oh real
yeah oh wow I think but not Asian guys
right no
but I heard you know what I heard in the
gay community Asian guys are very
popular
everybody likes Asian girls yeah
and in the gay community everybody likes
Asian boys
um yeah there's nothing to say I noticed
it's you guys I don't know do we have
any uh lgbtq members here just just Nick
just Nick oh okay I mean he's married to
a lady okay but deep inside they're not
convinced he's lgbj
that's being gay Brazilian
kind of true I think you're probably
lgbtq minus
what does the minus stand for
you know over here like uh most of the
racism would be like uh from white
people to minorities because white
people are the majority here yeah in
China when the teacher when he had an
American teacher were whether it was
there racism towards him yeah did they
go
oh my God he probably went to a good
school
everyone just wanted to study and do
more homework
but I
I don't think so because uh this is
probably true for a lot of Asian
countries they're very friendly to our
foreigners you know it's just a lot of
curiosity more than rate like hate and
yeah yeah yeah pretty respectful yeah my
my relatives from you know the
countryside sometimes they want to go to
Beijing just to see some foreigners
that's true too you know but but then
yeah but then
I rarely see people getting harassed
like bullying them and stuff yeah but I
didn't I didn't know about this stuff
after I came to America either you know
because I came here to study in that
environment
there's some racist stuff but then at
the time we had a
foreign student advisor she actually
told us be slow to take offense in
America
and another time we didn't quite
understand what was that you know but
then you just cut
it got thrilled into her mind just you
know learn stuff before you respond but
then over the years I gradually realized
oh there's a lot of [__] going on
but and uh
and later on another Discovery was uh
I didn't get this because I was from
China you know people who are born here
get this [__] too
yeah but in the beginning I didn't know
this I was like I think that beginning
is what makes immigrants so successful
sometimes because they don't know the
limitation oh yeah so I see a lot of
immigrants come here and like they don't
know the barrier they don't know maybe
they are being like like bullied or
racist but they don't even understand
exactly so they just keep going and
going and being super successful because
they don't have the the limitating
beliefs or once you know you're being
discriminated against you it's a bad
feeling you know it kind of it's a uh
inhibiting yeah it's hard to function oh
yeah exactly you know it's just like ah
[__] I didn't have to deal with a
negative feeling but if you just totally
ignorant about it you're probably doing
fine
that is true it's like your revenge is
the success oh yeah yeah that's yeah but
there's all these guys that like like
Joe who would come in and just like do
stand-up comedy without knowing that
there is a barrier like I I think
there's way more barriers from Asian
American Kids born here saying like oh
like we grew up and a lot of Asians were
saying oh we can't become fit
Asians can't become strong that's a lot
of people thought that and then we were
like but we have a bar we got a bark one
but we no but I couldn't believe it
because we the gym we would go to there
were so many fit Asians so at school
when people will say things like that
I'm like you live in a stupid world but
I can totally see you're [__] stupid
damn yeah
but I can believe that if I didn't see
business samples that contradicted the
statements you got to see the example
yeah because these stupid little biases
exist because people have anecdotal like
observations right they go oh yeah like
oh my uncles are weak as [__] so
therefore Asians are not capable of
being fit yeah but I I like this
discussion because uh
would you do something just because it's
against Asian stereotype you know like
because people think oh it's just not
fit I'm gonna you know go work out or
I'm gonna go play basketball would you
do it like as an action of defiance
exactly yeah I think it's just
coincidence like if you genuinely like
it oh okay yeah because I I don't think
it if it doesn't naturally align with
you it's hard to do something long-term
so I do think that people that like uh
maybe from the outside they're like oh
this guy's such a stereotype breaker but
really they're just pursuing what makes
them happy and then the people that
um aren't the ones that are projecting
like oh you know I can't like like when
we first got into like YouTube and Asian
entertainment we've heard so many Asians
complain about Asians can't get into
Hollywood or they can't do stand-up
comedy or they can't do whatever
and from people that are doers we're
just like you're just not a doer like
right I look at Joe Wong who comes here
and he's like I want to do this I'm
gonna keep doing this just doing it
you're just doing it rather than like
imagining these obstacles maybe the
obstacles do exist but they're just
doing it so much that they break past
the obstacles versus being like held
back by it yeah and then whenever I was
taking acting classes or just going into
these like networking events with Asian
entertainers or people trying to become
in the industry there were so many
excuses and limiting beliefs that I was
like I don't like this I just want to be
around people who want to create because
if you spend that time and energy just
creating instead of complaining you
actually get somewhere yeah and and so I
never grew up
I was always fascinated by that way of
thinking rather than being influenced
from that way of thinking oh that's a
good attitude you know yeah but I was
lucky because I think how I grew up was
unconventional in the way where like the
Asian stereotypes about my you know your
parents want you to be a doctor lawyer
whatever I didn't know that that was a
stereotype because my parents are
classical musicians so I know Asian kids
play piano and I I was a part of that
stereotype but I wasn't a part of the
doctor stereotype or like you know like
there's certain things that I think is
actually just Chinese culture but they
say it's Asian culture or like some
things might be like one type of Asian
but not like Filipino or whatever so I I
think this whole idea of like oh all
Asians do it this way I'm like eh I
don't know maybe Confucianism ties us
together but other than that I don't
know all Asians do eat ice cream with
their Chopsticks
well now they do yeah
it's kind of a solid burn my Chachi yeah
it's kind of sick one of the funniest
clips I recently saw was like Bobby Lee
was talking about how like nowadays
there's so many like um Asian stand-up
comedians going up to him going like oh
man like I love what you did for us like
it's so cool like you paved the road now
we can follow you and Bobby Lee was like
I'd do it for you
that is true that is always what happens
like even with with uh because my my
background's dance and then as soon as
like we got famous off of dance and then
there were all these things about wow
Asians can dance Asians can do this and
all the interviews that we would have
from Asian Publications were like how
did you manage to do this despite all of
the shortcomings that Asians have to go
through and like they want that answer
because that's what they're used to
running with and it's like you almost
have to [__] yeah because it's like
honestly it's hard for anybody because
you can't become a good dancer or really
good dancer for a different cause other
than I wanted to be a really good
exactly like yeah period yeah nobody out
there is good at what they do because of
the drive to prove Asians can do it yeah
you see but this is this is what this is
what blows my mind right because like
let's say you're an actor and let's say
like
statistically
there's 20 000 white male actors there's
only 100 Asian male actors
if they're looking for an Asian role for
this ensemble cast you have a better
probability of getting a role in this
film than one of the white guys do in
that film you know what I mean not if
you're fighting for the same role but
let's say there's a yeah there's a
ensemble cast one of them is the Asian
and one of them is the white right so
don't you technically have it easier
because your competition is less than
someone that has to compete amongst
twenty thousand yeah yeah well I guess
the flip side of the story is there's so
few of those roles no because I remember
I was talking to this uh writer Paula
you
she said she she worked on TV a lot of
the CW shows and stuff she said for a
while they were they were doing
auditions and she was just saying why
aren't all the Asian actors so bad yeah
and then she realized one thing
they don't get practice you know if
you're you're a white actor black actor
sometimes you get two auditions a day
proper is an actors that's you have an
audition every six months every audition
you got so nervous yeah even though you
prepare a lot you just you don't get
that much practice of course it can't be
that good you know yeah right but I'm
just glad that you know Asian American
literature and stuff is coming up so
there are more stories by ourselves
instead of you know some white guy rides
it for you you know then that's that's
that makes a huge difference there you
know it's what's even funnier is that
like the fact that someone's even
interviewing me asking me how I did it
despite the Asian shortcomings already
proves that I'm in a better climate than
the Asians who came before me and no one
gave a [__] to even talk to them oh yeah
oh yeah because they were good and no
one cared oh yeah yeah but they care now
so it's like I'm actually in a pretty
good spot yeah that's I that's I felt
the same way it took us I came up around
2010 2011 before fresh off the boat man
at the time
I got the best agent you know my agent
was a real models agent wow the best
production company in America which is
uh David Letterman's production company
they they made everybody Loves Raymond
the teammate uh what was they saw that
they made a couple of really successful
TVs yeah it's a great show yeah and I
have the best agent in Hollywood
we go to the pitching no one's
interested you know just climb it was
just so tough but now you know like if
you have a you know good Asian story you
know a lot of people bid for it right
now it's just so different though yeah
the momentum's hot right right now baby
they just needed a proof of concept so
like every single Asian content that's
been out has been doing fairly well so I
think like
after that
proof of concept now Holly was willing
to invest money yeah but we have to keep
up with this though because you know
Asia have to keep pumping out good
products because this actually happened
I would say 20 25 years ago you know
when I came to America I just remember I
was watching Margaret Chill on TV oh
right and movie theaters has uh The Joy
Luck Club yeah I was like Wow America is
great you know you know with the Asian
faces in you know in the media and stuff
but then after that just boom everything
just stopped yeah you have to keep the
momentum exactly because they died out
and just was dead for almost 20 years
yeah but I think America gets bored of
like so it's like it it yeah like
Latinos have their time it'll go to
Black and then there'll be eras of like
what's popular
but like I think what Asians never had
is their own
you know like bubble of purchasing
entertainment supporting yeah like black
community always had that like made in
Medea we need a media Series right oh
yeah yeah
us there's this other one Tyler Perry
yeah exactly because then no one can
tell him when to make movies yeah yep he
just makes just makes it all the time
doesn't have his own student he has his
own Studio yeah he's doing really well
yeah that's also when having the Asian
demographic backfires because they're
the cheapest customers oh dude true I go
watch that yeah they're like but you
know
we're the actual start of the era of
self-sustaining audience independent
yeah yeah like before us there was they
couldn't survive without Hollywood yeah
they had to that's true yeah but like
where we created the appetite and the
long time fan base yeah yeah so
I don't know man well kudos for you guys
I know how hard it is because I've been
through this [__] you know it's very
tough you know people just as soon as
they
I got four or five different writer as a
promoter it just say to my face oh we
can't have any Asian family shows I said
why they were like oh because Margaret
show failed I was like Jesus they will
never say this to a white guy you know
would you cancel Matthew Perry show you
know there won't be any white guys on
CBS
all because Joey failed
yeah they just say this to my face and
my manager at the time he was even
apology I was a skill I'm sorry that's
not this is not what America is like oh
yeah it's not what America is like it's
what America is you know just yeah it's
just everything's Gold by skin color so
this is how they're gonna do it I mean
it'll probably be a while before we have
a late night Indian woman host oh yeah
because Lily's thing didn't pan out
exactly sucks unless she's super fine
I think more than race though what rules
America's money and so if you can find
funding backing someone to invest in you
you create that show on your own you
make it successful a studio will buy it
after the after you show dollar signs so
it's always been a game of
because like if Bruce was still alive
today
easily get his films funded everything
because they know that that person can
sell a lot of these companies won't put
money behind brand new actors brand new
things
so I think at the end of the day like if
Asians can create a fund which I know
like gold house is trying to do and
things like that but we need our own
production houses with our there's tons
of wealthy Asians that can invest into
it oh crazy Rich crazy rich Asian but
that's I I know some of the billionaires
you know they they will not they're not
willing to fund anything they're not
interested in that yeah they want to get
their money back in three months even
though they're already billionaires
worst customers
there's no passion for the Arts but it
literally takes that like we if if we're
we can't ask White America to pay for it
you know what I mean like it's like
there are Asian billionaires
which one of them wants to bankroll it
and do it I can already see the
boardroom not me man not me man
funny too is how because of Chinese
distribution uh they're having to
implement Chinese actors in movies that
don't even call for a Chinese actor yeah
you know how they do that it's like oh
we're gonna make this character Chinese
because we want this movie to sell in
China oh yeah that's interesting but
that doesn't help independent actors
celebrities you ever see that it's like
it's probably like a c grade movie It's
called Meg meglin yeah the shark the
[__] yeah those random Chinese people
in it I'm like you don't need this but
I'm like it's probably for China it's
fun it's funded by China yeah it was a
Chinese like Studio though yeah it's
like Chinese Jaws well they add they add
whole scenes to the Chinese version yeah
that have more of a major role for that
Chinese character so distribution helps
but also it helps a guy that's already
on top I think we also need our own like
modern day Bruce Lee too like someone
that you put on the screen and then we
get that draw in the audience you know
so you have like white money black money
Hispanic money like everyone's down
because like so Bruce Lee came out
everyone's pain everybody was a fan yeah
what about uh simulu right now I don't
know if he has a Bruce Lee draw on yeah
probably not right now okay yeah Bruce
Lee I have to say he's the only Chinese
guy who can appear on the black guys
t-shirt
we haven't had a Bruce Lee since Bruce
Lee oh yeah yeah one of one bro
yeah I think what's different about him
is he was revolutionary and had his own
thoughts yeah actors
play out other people's thoughts yeah
they don't have their own actual
philosophy and voice and image and world
where Bruce Lee created worlds yeah so
that's a huge one yeah yeah that's
that's just something I can't I can't
master a swag you know
this is true you know sometimes I I
would go somewhere they were like oh we
need somebody cool swag you know just
show us some swag and I was like how do
I do that I have no concept that's been
a request that you passed oh yeah yeah I
was like Joan can you give us more sweat
oh yeah I was like what what the hell is
that that's even hard that's even hard
for a person that has swag to just turn
it on like hey show us some sweat yeah
exactly
that's how you turn the turn some swag
off
yeah swag's easy to turn off that's
right yeah turn off yeah yeah
that's a crazy ass by the way you know
uh I did do something because uh my
ethnicity though because
I did give up comedy for about a year
after my son was born wow you gave up
comedy yeah because I that's a few years
you know five or six years into it and
I'm not moving anywhere I mean my peers
are getting a TV spots so I quit for a
year or two
and then I went to uh we have a
collaboration with Harvard
I went to Harvard I was like Wow there
are a lot of Asians who are already like
professors you know
I just feel that in science field we
don't need another Asian guy yeah yeah
but instead of Comedy there's not a
whole lot of issues because this was in
Boston there's very few you know just I
always tell people there's a very
tight-knit Asian
comedy scene in Boston you know which is
pretty much myself you know
okay you know at least I should do
something interesting or different you
know that's kind of part of the
motivation for me to go back to the
comedy club too but yeah that's cool but
sometimes yeah I I guess probably just
another excuse I guess
that's cool I think you have swag Joe
foreign